[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
hi how's it going
thank you for joining for those of you
who are joining from the the choice
class thank you for sticking around
those of you who are new welcome so we
usually try to do the games of the week
that are being played live kind of
because that's my favorite type you know
live chess but since we're not really
getting any live chests any green person
chess we kind of are doing the online
ones and they're fun even though they're
not the classic time control they're
still pretty fun hi everybody
and also my biggest problem is that I
can't really find any game and like a
good game
in the top top players that other people
haven't done commentary on and I it's
kind of hard because I feel like I'm
just redoing somebody else's work so or
like there's so many different
variations of this game commentators out
there that it's just yeah I don't really
it doesn't feel that that's perfect to
me doesn't feel super original so now
that I vented a little bit about this
the problems now let's actually look at
the cool games right hello from Brazil
have been in Brazil in 2011 and thank
you thank you ranch for the nice words
okay so let's look at the game that's I
thought was kind of cool to speak their
game whistling vanish Gary
Aeon upon them napalm Lim Chee Oh almost
had it
ah my pronunciation skills okay um so
this is the game I wanted to show and
this game was played I think this was
the second round and yeah let's start
looking at the game okay so I think yeah
this was the game that - Gary Wong and
they kind of just Internet went crazy
but it's because I don't know why but
everybody thinks and agree it's like
equals draw I mean I don't get the
stigma but well people do so there's
that all right so we have a classical
kind of London on the board right and
now it just feels like it's like a let
me try to rephrase this right now this
kind of feels like a carro con right
like imagine if you started with E 4 C 6
and you kind of exchange this off so
it's like an exchange variation of what
is a pant part of boss panic yeah it's
something like that so it's like a it's
just completely it's a whole mix so it
started from London we ended in
caro-kann so talk about magic right okay
so in this position the first things to
notice is well as white you are not
trying to lose your pants so something
like Knight c3 is not the best idea
so the first thing to kind of start
absorbing is what do you want to do with
your night with your bishop your king
so these are like the little things to
start nah I'm acknowledging and so first
things first
right now Queen B 2 is happening so you
could ignore it you could just develop
the bishop but if take 92
you do have a good activity but you
can't simply just play 92 first because
this night does belong on d2 than
purchase e3 and ideally later on you
could push like c3 put this Bishop on d3
so yeah these are some of the ideas to
look on and yeah ranch yeah this game
has been like I like I know there are
official commentaries I'm pretty sure
everybody else on their channels are
also talking about it so I'm running out
of weekly the games of the week contact
need something original
send me your fun games guys ha we can
work on those but Knight c3 the London I
think my c3 is possible but a 92 is way
more desired avoids lots of the problems
with potential because you don't know
what to do with this knife later like
alright you still have to relocate it
somewhere but the night on d2 you could
have a clear idea on like you're
defending this is square you could think
about potentially 95 okay so 90 to 96 no
this guy is under attack also this guy
is under attack
so how to defend them boats 9 p3 right
and the game Bishop g4 was played I I to
me Bishop f5 seems a little bit more
like just logical just to me but I don't
play I played Carrick on just a few
times at black so I I mean I'm not the
expert on it but Bishop a5 does seem
pretty doable
especially because after Bishop f5 kind
of take away this Bishop d3 idea and
that's what I kind of like about it so
in a game they played Bishop g4 though
yeah
so if Bishop g4
actually in the game they played a four
which I thought was very interesting and
a four
it's kind of fun fact the school with my
chest philosophy because the idea with a
four is kind of to push a five maybe not
right now but eventually also getting a
square for Bishop b5 it's really
interesting you just you are getting a
lot of space advantage with just a
little move such as a four so that is
why I really like this is a four idea so
a four then in the game I assume I yeah
this was a novelty Bishop f3 but I don't
know how like if other people would
repeat it later on like if it's desired
because something like a six doesn't
make sense to me a six a five you play
put the Queen away like this was
actually a game between Carlson and
Aronian in 2019 that they just played it
like this and across and up winning the
game but doesn't necessarily mean white
is winning just well Carlson played this
game better but also I do prefer White's
position right in this position it's
just like Bishop if I could get this
Bishop to f4 and this night is better
what are you doing with your Bishop this
pawn on e5 is very strong later on and
controlling a b4 I do like this position
more for white okay so let's go back to
here after Bishop takes after e Queen f3
logical right the first glance I thought
maybe white black wants to actually go
after the pawns because then I mean why
else would you take Bishop f3 just just
looking at the game the first thing I
saw is this but after Queen like take
doesn't really work as well if take
whoops take just Bishop b5 check right
and now black is kind of
not getting castle and this is not the
good kind of not castling that we've
been seeing and like the past hour and
Tuesday
this is not the type of not Castle and
yet you want to do this is not that is
not it
there's like bunch of tea once the file
is falling oh god this is not let's not
do that alright so that is why taking
the pawn is not a good idea so in the
game Napo just played a six iron it was
so much easier than trying to pronounce
the whole name yeah I should just cut
everybody's name to just four letters
I'll be Dara everybody else just give me
your first four letter of last name
there we go okay um so oh hello from
California well hello from San Louis
after ecigs mm Giri played Queen t1
which was very kind of hard for me to
understand what is the idea of Queen d1
because like I get it that you Queen
doesn't really belong on f3 but at the
same time I thought I was thinking maybe
like Queen III to just keep the Queen in
the sense like centre-half this like
Bishop beef Bishop d3 ideas I thought
that is why but I yeah it for me it was
a little hard to understand Queen d1 so
if you do fully understand it
congratulations
alright so Queen d1 and again they just
played a 6 C 3 I assume that Queen D
want hats on it too with C 3 but I just
thought maybe teacher is not that that
necessary I thought maybe we could just
play Queen the Queen three Bishop d3
castle and then worry about c3 but yeah
I was a little bit wrong Queen D 1 C 3
is necessary so in the game neppo just
waited 94-94 is very interesting because
94 well the question is for white what
do you want to do after 94 Bishop d3 I
mean it's possible but what is your next
move
like hold on let me rephrase that
would you prefer to play Bishop d3
castle or would you prefer to play a
five gain the space gain the squares in
the queenside den play Bishop d3 sorry
for my little bat phrasing all right so
after a five Queen ha does have to go
back right so it's between D eight and a
seven D 8 makes more sense because what
is the queen doing an i7 like it doesn't
it doesn't make sense a so Queen the 8th
Bishop d3 Bishop d6 now my first
question for the audience do you want to
exchange the bishops like do you want to
take Bishop 66 or do you want to like
well anything else beside pick up d6 and
remember as always if you say Bishop d6
don't just tell me White's move like if
you're telling me Bishop d6 make sure to
tell me like Queen d6 or 96 something
for black - so if you're telling me
Queen c1 maybe give me a little bit more
like we see one before like Quincy one
Queen c7 something like that just so
that I have a just so that I understand
you're not just shooting moves and
you're actually thinking about your
opponent - that's a good practice my my
coaches growing up made me do that they
actually made me write it down it was
kind of painful so many lines and yeah
oh thank you that's very nice of you
Thank You Bishop g3 possibly a special
g3 bishop g3 also possible 9 thanks g3
so a cube are you if you're suggesting
Queen f3 can you give me something for
black to so I agree I don't like Bishop
d6 because it's better to keep the
tension because Bishop d6 96 95 is
possible but then I mean just Castle
before they're there possible but it's
just it's it feels like you that's black
just get away easy you could just play
it a little bit better keep tension
stuff like that so bishop g3 i I'm not
the biggest fan of Bishop g3 because
well what if Knight takes I don't really
like that so I did have a Queen f3 but
no follow-up so Queen f3 how do you know
when it's good to resolve the tension or
not that's a very good question
so let me think let me think how to
answer that so most of the time it's a
good idea to keep the tension just
because psychologically it's also
putting attention but the times that you
actually have to decide to resolve it is
usually when you're getting something
out of it's not just out of running
impatience so like if you're getting a
square out of it if you're getting an
outpost out of it getting some material
out of it usually a good idea to solve
the tension but so I think what you're
saying about Bishop d3 but now what if
black tries to start opening up the
center because well this is a good
Bishop controlling all of the squares so
potentially could consider something
like queenie 75 what do you want to do
with your king short Casto your phone is
on if to g3 long castle wool your pawn
is on a 5 so I don't truly I want to
play Bishop g3 in my game
if you feel brave enough to do that and
then King f1 feel free to do so
okay okay another thing to actually
consider after Bishop g3 that I'm
thinking is what if something like f5 if
take yeah take with the Queen I'm not
the biggest fan of a5 but I think it's a
good thing to at least look at so let's
go back so let's look at Queen f3 Queen
f3
I think Queen c7 doesn't really work
anymore cuz you can't simply just take
on t6 and now you're threatening to take
efore right and we don't really want
that
so instead of doing that we could think
about Knight xt6 but then again 95
getting to all the squares or Queen g3
pinning the night all right so what else
do they think about ah so in the game
Napo played Bishop a4 which is the best
move so see this is one of those times
that neppo decided to resolve the
tension because if Bishop if the bishop
F force don't happen then the e4 Knight
is under - under pressure so either you
have to move the knight and give up the
c5 square or you gotta just exchange
this bishops right um f5 I mean f5 is
possible but
I'm a little worried about something
like check g6 maybe Queen f6 again you
can take take but this is now a not very
ideal to try and castle into right so
that's why so that's the Bishop f4 queen
of four and the game they've just played
nine times six which I agree with again
that's something like f5 I mean it looks
aggressive but so many different just
like there's so many holes in the
position it doesn't make that much sense
to try and just give it that all of that
up yeah exactly if I was weakening thank
you okay so um in this game take take
Knight f6
so now after negative six finally castle
castle now another idea that white could
follow up with is something like work
you won
so rookie won the first thing that I'm
thinking is can I bring this rig up an
attack maybe but the game is kind of
widescreen this kind of sets on the
Queen side as well so rook e1 is
definitely interesting but I don't think
we are gonna play something like a
cookie tree yeah crickets Orchestra
attack right I mean I like kids but in
the game so nipple here just play a drug
I ate and after we create gear we just
decided to play Ricky - it's your move
my cookie - is a little hard for me to
understand because just if you're gonna
play Ricky - why not Ricky three that's
just my way of just I couldn't
understand what's the difference between
jerky 200k three I think the thing with
rookie 3 is maybe you should start
watching us for a files but I just don't
think a 5 is good idea
it doesn't make much sense and they
leaving the kingside I don't know I I do
like her III just as much as rookie too
but yeah I that's one of the things I'm
gonna have to look into deeper the
difference between roofie to and Ricki
tree may be blocking the Queen yeah I
guess that's a good reason but blocks
the Queen to where you're not really
planning on bringing the Queen back
anytime soon so a little hard to digest
okay so no he ain't Ricky - ha
good good once Lemmy all right so there
he a turkey - rupee aids in this game
Giri played a stray I guess a Sri is one
of those lovely prophylaxis moves for
the King in the future that we all love
to do because we don't know what else to
do right well that was a long sentence
so after H 397 my first question my
second question for you guys
why'd you move what do you want to do
and don't just give me one move either
give me like why does this black does
that or give me like an idea of you want
to do this with that idea so I can know
that you are actually thinking and
figuring stuff out
well you guys are really doing your
learn to weekly to egt okay chess King
or I guess Oliver I see you I see your
your try for attack but it's not gonna
work
whoa you guys are really thirsty for
some attack aren't you we just did
another kind of like a tactical thing
like an hour ago now oh my god
the horse chest King sorry I do have
another chess King in another class who
apparently is Oliver shoo oh boy okay I
don't know why I think I have it Oliver
scratch that
um alright so I okay so this attack the
idea with Rick III worksheet read does
not work right now
mainly because well there's a queen of
six that stops at all and you also with
playing a street you took away their
acacia tree ideas so not that what else
you got what other piece can you advance
I apologize just king it's kind of hard
for me to remember the names when I
actually well I only hurt them once or
twice
feel free to remind me every time you
want to 92 93 is an interesting idea
bringing a knight to this side cool just
be careful with losing this pawn we like
that pawn we kind of like keep that pawn
hmm kook wendy6 is an interesting idea I
do like the idea Queen d6 so maybe let's
think a little bit deeper about Queen d6
- so chess King I don't think Knight t2
is going to work in this position not
only because of your pawn on a5 but also
because the Queen f6
here the attack is not really going to
work because let's say you've been
getting this night all the way up to g5
- just like it cannot easily be stopped
with a 96 so yeah Queen d6 right so
Queen d6 is the best one after Queen d6
yeah something like 95 is also a great
idea something else does we could
consider is well with night with Queen
d6 you don't necessarily have to have
all the moves figured out but Queen d6
is one of those moves that's it puts
your opponent's position and pressure so
the last move here let's go a little
back Blackfyre create right so it
repeats what is the idea to push me be
the b-pawn maybe right so it is a good
idea to play this Queen d6 - exactly to
restrict it to restrain it to just
basically tie your opponent's hands
everything by by alpha or branch
hopefully I'm right about that okay so
after Queen d6 it is kind of important
to just keep in mind what you're doing
and not rush into it thank you
psychologically harmful to your opponent
thank you
so for those of you who have been
watching my videos or the twitch channel
for the club that I stream on I've been
talking a lot a lot about my philosophy
of chess about how you should play and
knowing chess you shouldn't just let
your opponent mmm do whatever he wants
and sometimes just saying a knowing
chest sounds weird because people are
like so should I kick my opponent under
the table no not that kind of a knowing
respectful like you're respectful you're
respectful but you look at the
chessboard and you figure out okay my
opponent wants to play this for example
here my opponent might want to play like
B 6 + White Queen D 6 - stop it like
something like that like you figure out
what your opponent wants to be wants to
do you put a stop to it
thank you I have a good translator thank
you
Muhammad for being my translator here
okay great
so I'm glad we got that out of the way
so after Queen d6 netbook kind of
realized that well this position is not
very ideal because well what are you
gonna do move the roof to see it move
this Knight to where your position is
kind of like just your hands are really
tied up so in this position nipple
played Queen e7 I kind of do understand
the concept behind Queen d7 because your
idea is kind of simple you want to
simply get your pieces out you want to
exchange some pieces yeah so Queen e7
when you play Queen d6 you can should
psychologically be ready for Queen e7
because if Queen e7 just come back well
then your Queen d6 was pretty pointless
and another thing to think about is well
in any given position one of the good
ideas to try and evaluate the position
is to think about the endgame think
about if you're if the Queen's are off
the board if like the rooks are off the
board like try and imagine if the
different pieces are off the board does
that help you if it does then go for it
like if you think the exchange of this
bishop and this Knight will help you
then you can start figuring out the way
to go after that
why not tonight they're there it's
possible but even if you come to a five
I'm just gonna pick that night up with
my bishop Josh all right oh that's a
great cool what about Fisher thank you
the way I translate it for myself is not
to just be disrespectful to the opponent
to kick anymore like make noises and not
that just like figure out what they want
to do block it sometimes a little bit of
stare doesn't hear it all right um I
have some good pictures and I'm staring
with my poly all right back to chest
okay so in this position after Queen d6
Queen e7 it is a good idea to exchange
the Queen's why because well this
possess endgame just imagine if this was
a pawn and game oh boy
it is great right your pawn is already
super advanced you just need to figure
out the way to break through maybe a B 3
C 4 go a little farther get this King in
that's the winning pawn in the game
right there
even if not pawn and game the endgame is
advantageous for white mainly because of
how much space white ties right so 9
take C 7 you get this off Lauren so to
me that idea before is pretty clear
takes away any hope of ePHI view oops
nope we don't want to play 5 you are
gaining as much space as you can in both
sides of the board next you can go after
g4 because now there's no Queens on the
board your king is not going to go on
their threat so it's a good idea to
start gaining space and you have enough
space on the Queen side so all you can
do now is get the space in the king side
right so F for Napoli h5 g for taketake
keep with g6
so now f5 is actually kind of I don't
know f5 it does make sense to me okay
but it feels a little premature like f5
take take
or what if take would eat and then take
them with the night yeah feels a little
premature so that's why we need to
prepare it's better so how do we prepare
this f5
so quiet um sub-zero
well isn't that a restaurant around here
sub-zero IRA capsule is interesting but
not exactly you kind of want to use the
other work so suggesting pawn breaks on
the other side of the court on c4 it's
possible but it's not really what you're
looking for you you don't know you don't
know if you want to make that kind of
commitment so tipsy for taketake nights
here and then you're giving your
opponent some chances to breathe so that
is why he won is the best know if it's
y2 up done f5 right then this night is
pinned can't really take thank you okay
so after he won you get this ninety-six
actually 96 was a bad idea because might
have six and others f5 take take take
and now white is advantageous but before
we hit a little bit deeper here because
right now there's Rick f1 and also there
is 95 both of them white has good
advantage let's go back a little over
here so instead of Knight f6 Black has a
better move can you guys think about it
and let me know so black to move how to
hold the position
[Music]
um f5 there's just Ricky sing so I'll
just eat your pond and I'll be sure to
say thank you
what else
same idea if you touch your f phone I'm
gonna eat the e-cigs so it's white to
move it's black to move chess King king
of to g3 nice idea but it's black to me
King f8 yep you guys are correct King f8
is the best one because nothing
effective f5 just take take whoops
take Knight takes if you take take I
mean now those are two pounds is okay
and the other problem is that remember
when we talked about negative six
after f5 take take take there's Knight
c5 right we don't really want that so if
the knight is back on d7 this Knight is
kind of paralyzed on b3 but not
paralyzed kind of restricted let's go
with that okay so let's see back in the
disposition Ricky one Knight of 6 f5
take take take in this position I do
okay if it was me if I was the one
playing I would definitely play 95 I
wouldn't waste more time but he'd agree
decided to play Rick f1 which is again a
good idea just not the best one like the
second best because like okay this
position this 95 goes with my chest
philosophy and I really like it
so all right there's a question about g5
let's go back g5 I'm just gonna take
that if you put a g5 I will take that
and I will send you tank your card about
eating the pond so also you're opening
up your king or case your - coming up no
that doesn't work
g5 f5 okay I see your point
yeah exactly also okay let's I wanted to
mention if g5 f 500 mean I don't know if
I
I'm not sure if this is the position
you're talking about but this does not
work though for whites instead of where
after like nine times six g5 you Bund
you're never gonna get that five it's
unnecessary ponpon movements you have a
clear plan you can just continue with
this if you put f5 well there's 94 now
it doesn't make much sense well thank
you for participating though okay so
take their work upon so here you're upon
place 94 your opponent displaying good
94 was excellent move and it's kind of
restored to balance and gives black some
chances to find ideas to get away right
so it is white to move what do you want
to do do you want to take on e4 do you
want to ignore this ninth you want to
just give check what do you want to do
take a look at four we're good for what
if just like my g3 kind of like these
nights or 96 these nights are just
monsters so let's take the night yeah
let's take the night you take back i
play night c5 so after night c5 what
white is trying to do is eat the pawn
right because be careful I mean not that
much careful because 93 doesn't exist or
is rupees 4 but be careful if you take
it then I mean technically it's possible
but I was kind of worried about my d6
and then this night is just chilling
there checked which King goes away I was
trying to figure out a way for whites to
play it a little bit more sneaky so
Knight c5 you are keeping some ideas
alive maybe some like 97's coming up
taking away the king d8 King f8 ideas
yeah to me this King like taking away
the King f8 ideas or trying to kind of I
like that it kind of makes sense to me
but okay so after Knight c5 what do you
think black should do this is a very
crucial moment so black has to play all
the rights moves in order to be able to
get away with it
one mistake and you're kind of already
in a pickle okay so if it's white to
move again what do you think white wants
do you see any maybe holes to try and
get into you know this little cute ones
over here we need this night to get here
thank you
97-90
right so and I see five another idea is
this little fork and then that little
fork so thank you thank everybody I
guess my little fake cop did it for you
gave you the idea good good
glad to be inspirational all right um so
I I mean I guess a normal person could
just play with th avoid this oh wait
that checks I'm just like continue this
but it's like a kind of a unpleasant
idea so I mean it's possible but I just
I don't want to do that like okay let's
say Ricky even like working for to try
and minimize possible future checks
you're like get the rookie in the game I
I mean it takes a lot of strain to play
Kenya it's like Napa did King f8 is the
best move like super cool move because I
think the idea is pretty simple checking
up you take me I'm gonna play 93 your
knight is trapped I'm gonna take one of
your ex I'm gonna pick up that night and
this is a doable endgame right so now
like what do you want to do I guess well
it's I mean something you don't even
take this right now I mean technically
you could take care of five because for
a second I was thinking about a five but
then there's 99 a six and now this is
better for whites but these two are too
strong go boy I mean this is nice takes
on a six is better compared to not
taking on a six oh yeah
but yeah right now you can't really do
night I mean you could tonight a six but
night f2 and then this night becomes a
little too advantageous and I don't
really like that so alright let's go
back to this position so that's why in
the game gear dinner point ninety seven
surprised because ninety seven King g7
take take I mean take my g3 and this
not very pleasant end game for white so
let's not denied t7 let's take this pawn
we're covering this g3 square the king
is still a little bit weak and things
are good right
so black boys King King g7 we bring in
our King ricochet to save the king g8
now in this position
oops it is oh sorry lot of movements it
is why to move what do you want to do
with white keep in mind this rook is
looking at this king that's one thing to
look at
so while you guys are thinking about
possible moves I'm gonna tell you
something that happened on the stream
today I was I was I mentioned that my
back kind of hurts and the viewers
advised me to stops sitting like this
what is it's called slouching I guess so
I'm trying to sit upright and that even
hurts more I don't know how you guys do
this all right we got this I see some
work at fives
I see some I see some D fives I see some
rafters
all right good I see some cool ideas you
guys are good all right so um why not
double the rooks on a file so when we
play 97 check it would be safe I guess
you're still talking about the position
with the King on f8 because even if you
double the rock up just King g7 you
don't have anymore Knight d7 tracks all
right
I like the Rudy 5 here right d5 is great
if you take it
oops if you take it my g3 I'm gonna take
your night there we go now it's time to
party after that okay so ah Thank You
Dennis that's very nice of you to say so
all right yep you played d5
now you're waiting for your opponent to
make mistakes so in the game an epic
player catch six which is a good move or
catch six still fighting still defending
all of them us all of those at the same
time so why it has a very cool move
think about it also remember the
question about when to keep the tension
when to resolve it you can't think about
it here do you think it's a good idea to
resolve the tension or do you prefer to
keep the tension don't forget as usual
if you're giving me a move for white
give me the move for black - if you're
saying detail xe6 give me the move for
black - guys you're cat5e takes up five
give me that move for black we need four
moves
should become a damn I guess a motto I
should maybe keep a banner right here
thank you if these weeks night takes
this is night takes D six then what
alright so de 6f e 6 I agree
Nene 6f e 6 well then what is what do
you want to do after that I don't really
see how to forward this I mean you could
try something like 95 to maybe push for
there but then there are 90 trees I
think the biggest problem right now so
yeah let me rephrase that
thank you for giving me full replies I
see a might see 5 ok nice if I was
interesting but ok I'm not gonna play b6
the basketball is not g3 attacking both
to your ex and I mean even rebuked Siwon
is possible but then like look g6 it
kind of takes away your mojo takes away
the flow of the game also I think maybe
taking as possible I guess technically
you take over there maybe Knight goes to
F for EM I mean it's possible this pond
is falling that kind of worries me for
black but take maybe take baby check I
don't know it feels like you're giving
away too much game for black and that's
the one thing I don't like so let's try
and figure out the one move that helps
whites win this game how to apply more
pressure thank you for giving me more
than just white smooth
so if recap 5 EF 595 just King goes to
f8 if King d8r King d6 yeah might have 7
wins the move wins the game you're right
but so why to move give me a move that
just puts pressure and remember how we
talked about this night g3 being a
problem maybe takes care of that
workout 5 doesn't work her cat that just
takes back you don't really have any
follow-ups what else
how to bring more pressure for keV to
look at for all right I like these two
good good I kind of like work out for
more just because well if work f2 it
feels a little forced
I don't really know what I'm doing with
these two over here but it's just a
little something York f3 I think I guess
it could work too I guess but Sarika 4
is the bus you're just bringing more
pressure keeping your tab on this line
and that night so looking for and the
game your cash one is played this is not
the best move the best was actually
earth t8 which forces you to take take
and then it's said draw well it's equal
position I guess the best the biggest
problem with drug f2 is the the rook t8
idea again take then there's like
Turkish ones so that's something that we
didn't want we don't want to have yes so
after working for rook t8 was the best
but never missed it and he just went
through catch one they were dirty so
Bashar you're right if Ricky if in this
whoops if in this position we played
rook EF - I understand about 93 but
black would never play 93 why would I
leave my pawn and f7 defenseless I I
don't think that's a logical way to
think about it like okay I might put
your q7 first with idea 93 but okay I
appreciate you giving me your inputs
okay let's go back to Rakesh Juan King
d2 just don't play King f2 please oh boy
okay
King king d2 is the best one so now we
actually want to take over there right
want to take over there and give this
check and pick this guy up clear right
so in the game nipple actually blundered
and he forgot about the stroke at five
or just simply blundered this work at
five
she should've played wreckage 6 because
this rook believe bull belongs on h6 and
the 6th file 6th rank because you are
defending this you need this rook to be
a good defender over here whereas in the
game worked e8 now what do we do
it's pretty cool just very easy to do we
already talked about it it's a boom move
does playing blindfold and leeches
improve my game I mean I I mean playing
blind fool generally helps you develop a
better imagination and if you actually
can hold up your position on why not
it helps you in your future calculation
Oh guys hold on first think about takes
and checks before you start thinking
about C fours yeah here we got five good
job Rick at five is the best one we just
talked about it this boom
Brooke why bye there we go so now after
rook d5 does this is a better endgame
just king of King III and yes we lost
bunch of pawns but this is like you
could just play wreckage - and next move
this is very better winning chances
however in the game Gary played bad and
played 9f2 now your key five would
actually hold the game rookie five king
Ditu king g6 kind of waiting for someone
to take that drug kind of ease it yeah
it's not that easy I agree but it's way
more winnable than the position we have
like through five moves ago right okay
so okay for now in this game before I
like before kind of Custer look stops
off the pawn movements a five-night d3
take take just have to be very careful
because if you also lose this pawn then
it's gonna be a kind of a slippery slope
right you're not gonna be able to win
this unless
something some blunders theoretically
you wouldn't be able to win this Brook
and recognizes again the rook is not
winnable so see thanks before Napa
Patrick a six and then played route t6
but rooks c6 was better because York c6
now you just get to bring in your king
and this trick is also kind of keeping
this night under tap and if you try and
take it
there's always repeat six so there is
that yep okay so let's go back to the
game here neppo just wait rickety six
again if you take it be careful there
three sixes so in order to be able to
take that pawn we could consider trying
to exchange the rooks right so Rick D -
all right so you're D - well in the game
they played f4 but f4 isn't necessarily
the best move because well this is kind
of a free pawn I can just take that if
you take this there's a cool fork right
yeah I don't know why they did that in
the game I guess time trouble maybe yeah
it was better to just play her c6 it
works c6 just if now you can take cuz
therefore p6 and oops
but there is your t6 and now this pawn
is a little bit monstrous so I guess
that was another way to deal with it so
f4 check take in the game was played
rooks e6 but now this is easy all right
you already ate some of the pawns and
you are going better it's going better
for you so just bring in the King closer
get the King closer starts pushing start
pushing the King away now relocating the
night - probably D sinks threatening up
seven tries any everything
keep your pieces intact not finally 96
this phone is also falling and after
that pond falls then this is super
winning raids like whatever you do I'm
gonna just eat that guy and later I'm
gonna pick this pawn up with mine I
found this is super winning right okay
so that's the game I wanted to show you
about this week it was a very
interesting game because it hit a lot of
different topics it started with some
good strategy put that pawn on e5 and
enemy cuts a little bit better by some
little tactics in the endgame and
eventually the black kind of broke under
pressure and made some mistakes so this
is a very interesting game make sure to
follow the remainder games of the chess
table and yeah well I hope you guys had
fun have a great fourth of July weekend
and I will see you later
have fun
you